[Music]
[Applause]
kevin o'connell the first year minnesota
vikings head coach and of course was
with the rams last year with their super
bowl run coach good to have you on again
uh
when do you get your super bowl ring
i was actually able to uh make it back
uh towards the end of the summer right
before training camp got to uh go back
to la with uh not only myself but two or
three of our other coaches
i brought here with me we all flew back
for the day and
it was actually really cool i mean that
you know that was the first time
i've ever been a part of something like
that but an actual ceremony where you
just realize how
two things really you realize how hard
it is to win a super bowl bowl but then
keep that team together because there
was a lot of players that had moved on a
lot of coaches that had moved on to some
different spots and to get that group
together one final time uh like that and
for me it i you know i flew out to
minnesota about 48 hours after the super
bowl game so i hadn't really seen
anybody post game outside of a couple
players and matthew and cooper and
obviously sean so it was great to see
everybody the ring is unbelievable
um don't really know what i'll do with
it ever other than just lock it away and
hopefully you know not lose it
um how many times were you cut during
your career you played for what six
teams
uh i played four so let's go through it
so i was drafted by new england um
played their first season my second
training camp there towards the end i
got let go
i thought i was going to get reunited
with josh mcdaniels he had taken the
bronco job that year but i was not
unfortunately i i did go to the detroit
lions who had the priority claim
uh that year and then got traded a day
later to the jets where i was there for
three years
uh had a stint in miami in training camp
um had a stint with the chargers to
finish up so all those times dan
um unfortunately i was sitting in the
head coach's office getting cut uh you
know so probably about four five six
times total um at different times and
and uh
you know heard heard a familiar familiar
story most of the times but uh
it was uh it was all part of the journey
to probably lead me and i say lead me
probably shove me more so into the
coaching profession yeah because at some
point you have to say i'm not going to
make it as a quarterback in the nfl
now do you say it or is it told to you
that you know what maybe you need to
start thinking about another line of uh
work
depends who you talk to uh because early
on early on it was you know here's what
you need to do to improve
um you know for me i always just felt
like i
i knew where to go with football but i
just wasn't naturally accurate enough to
you know play at the elite level that
you have to throw the ball with in this
league but uh as i as i kind of moved
forward it was i don't know whether it
was rex ryan's
just brutal honesty sometimes but uh
there was a couple times where he said
you know you're gonna make a heck of a
coach one day
so i uh and and he didn't always say at
that politically correct but i i i'll
tell you this much some of the greatest
coaches i've been around
um i was lucky because they didn't miss
out on a chance to tell me hey have you
ever thought about coaching you ever
thought about uh you know that that
being kind of your uh you know your
life's work a lot of people rex included
mike pettin who's here as our assistant
head coach here was the d coordinator
when i was with the jets i spent a lot
of time with those guys on that side of
the ball
um they had their they had their own way
of saying it that's for sure but uh
i'm very thankful they did because they
planted the seed and then and then
ultimately you know i didn't miss a
chance throughout from my rookie year on
maybe i should have been worrying more
about throwing the ball instead of just
thinking all the time but
i didn't miss a chance to be absorbing
things that i really do feel like helped
me to this very day
four career completions
i think is it four or six i think you
were four for six
that sounds right i see i didn't worry
too much about whether it got completed
i just threw it six times
uh do you remember all four completions
i think i do
i think i do
um i know for sure the miami game that
was the famous uh you know wildcat game
with ricky williams and uh ronnie brown
if you remember
got to play a good chunk of that second
half and then i played a little later on
in that year it was about 15 degrees
versus
the arizona cardinals they eventually
went to the super bowl that year but
they didn't have much desire to be
playing in late december in foxborough
in the snowstorm yeah remember that
remember that
how would you sum do you have an idea
how good your team is right
now you know i i do i i think we you
know i feel really good about where
we're at i feel really good about how
things have kind of come together would
you tell me if you didn't feel good
right now about your team i would not
[Laughter]
and i can honestly tell you i feel very
good about where we're at uh
schematically you know putting in the
systems we put in really an offense and
defense and special teams and then
really kind of the the roster that we
inherited here with some great veteran
leadership obviously some some young
talented players and then i think quasi
and his staff and our coaching staff
combined
have done a nice job adding some real
integral parts of of really our team
that will give us some depth but also
guys that will play very significant
roles for us
i thought you were going to go into
broadcasting
i thought that's what you wanted to do
that if this didn't work out were you
close to going into broadcasting as
opposed to coaching
uh i was i was i actually i i got a
chance to do it you know you know not
significantly but i got a chance to
broadcast some games got a chance to do
some studio shows and things like that
and i really enjoyed it because i
thought it was a way to stay around the
game and you know i could watch tape and
come up with ways i thought teams would
win the game and advantages they had and
then be able to kind of talk about those
you know if possible and
and and really what happened dan is
when i first got them playing you know
my wife she's turned into an
unbelievable coach's wife i mean we've
got our fourth kid on the way
due this year and and i don't know how
she does it some days um but
it was really just a family decision at
first
where i just thought hey you know what
we've been traveling around a lot uh you
were always with me every step of the
way when i was going from city to city
as player uh why don't we just hit the
pause button for a second i'll try to
you know make this career work and i
enjoyed it but ultimately there was
always just something missing for me
as far as you know just being truly in
it being in it on a day-to-day basis
being around the players being around
coaches
um that when i got the opportunity to
coach quarterbacks in 2015
i jumped at it and really haven't looked
back since
did you schedule the childbirth around
the football season
we did not um we did not at all we uh we
actually just uh enjoyed the super bowl
in the super bowl after
[Laughter]
if you name it cooper or stafford
stafford o'connell
how do you think that sounds
i like cooper o'connell
or cup o'connell cup o'connell
there you go there you go well uh we do
know it's gonna be a girl so working
that in when it'd be a little bit more
difficult okay so all right but yeah
i'll let you you got to get back to me
on that because i know you and the
fellas can probably give us some good
some good thoughts there uh i got you
guys making the playoffs so don't screw
it up because
i've i've done the hard work to predict
this now you guys got to go out there
and you know shouldn't be asking much i
mean you know packers no big deal you
don't have to worry about the bears of
the lions so just the packers that's not
a big deal i get 10 wins out of you guys
right
i'll tell you what i think our i think
obviously led by the packers i think our
division is going to be you know a
really really strong division because i
got a lot of respect for dan campbell
and that coaching staff and they've
clearly you know improved their roster
and obviously brad holmes i was with
their general manager i was with him in
los angeles i know he they know how to
build
you know a tough you know
football team they've added a lot of
talent you know around the skilled
positions around jared and obviously my
background with jared and then you know
obviously uh you know coach iber flews
there in chicago with with a good young
quarterback i mean our division
kind of where it's at right now and
obviously the green bay has been the
standard um we've got a lot of work to
do in the division we get three home
games in the division and in our first
six games so
a lot of work to be done early
and and we're we're looking to try to
come out of the gates as fast as
possible you're saying all the right
things coach speak you are oh come on
you got it you got it down there you
know you look good in purple by the way
too
yeah thank you for that thank you hey
stay in touch good luck and uh thank you
for joining us kev yeah i appreciate you
dan
kevin o'connell just turned 37 got
another child on the way super bowl baby